This video is sponsored by skillshare.
The first thousand people to sign up
with the link in the description.
We'll get their first two months for
just 99 cents.
Hey,
wise crack jared.
Again.
While we were working on our philosophy
of Savio,
I came across something very unexpected.
Apparently critics have noted a
structural similarity between the soft
films and French philosopher John Paul
Sartre is famous play no exit,
so I watched all seven movies,
read no exit and immediately called
Bolt.
The connection was too tenuous.
Then Jigsaw came out and when I saw this
I was like,
Huh,
welcome his wife's crack condition on
the philosophy of Jigsaw and if you want
more jigsaw related content,
head on over to wise crack plus on
Patrion for an exclusive podcast that
dives deeper into the movie and as
always,
spoilers and decapitations ahead like
all saw movies,
Jigsaw starts with a game.
Each player has to confess the horrible
sin that snag them and exclusive invite
to the world's worst warehouse party.
If they don't confess,
they'll turn dead AAF given the chance
to save their skin.
Each of the players take a solid pass
offering.
Half-Baked Confession,
not an accident.
10 minutes after I felt like to work
professing their innocence Honi my soul
is clean.
So one by one they're voted off the
island.
Meanwhile,
an assortment of Sketchy Detectives and
forensic pathologist try to figure out
why gnarly corpses keep popping up all
over the city could the very much dead
John Kramer Bita blame.
Eventually the film's creepy detective
and creepy forensics guy come face to
face in the ultimate creep off and we
find out that the forensics guy is the
new jigsaw you're working around.
I am man.
Oh and by the way,
everything you just watched actually
happened 10 years ago.
But don't worry about that.
Instead of focusing on the timeline
fake-out we're zeroing in on what brings
fans to the soft films in the first
place.
I want to play a game.
The wholesome games.
See in the past,
jigsaw had one main party trick building
traps to heinously and creatively
torture people.
But in the latest film,
Jigsaw has moved into a more
psychological realm,
forcing his victims to confess their
worst sins.
Both versions of the game consist of
forcing a person to choose between two
unattractive options.
There was only one open the decline
in the first seven films.
Cramer asked each victim to choose
between door a inflict excruciating pain
on themselves or others or door b give
up and die,
but in Jigsaw it,
the game's been updated.
Now his victims must choose between door
a confessed to their worst sin in front
of a group of strangers and make it home
in time for adult swim or door be die a
painful death.
While I am sure there is a desire to
point fingers at me to the blog,
that has been shit,
unless you can turn that thing inward,
I assure you more blood will be lost.
The game is still sprinkled with head
gnashing,
leg ripping devices,
et Cetera,
but these are more of a side show,
a background threat perhaps to encourage
honesty.
The evolution of Jigsaws gain positions,
the act of confessing as the painful
alternative to death,
the central form of suffering that takes
place in the film.
Unlike the other films,
confession,
not to be burning,
slashing,
or ripping a flesh is treated as the
harder,
more pain inducing moral alternative to
instant death.
But let's backtrack for a second.
What moves jigsaw to devote his life to
making diy medieval torture devices in
the first place?
As we explained in our philosophy of saw
episode Kramer shares the early
Christian view that suffering can be
transformative and even life changing,
so enduring his traps can strengthen a
person's moral character and even redeem
them for past naughtiness.
As leader of this crossfit for the soul,
Jigsaw establishes himself as a godlike
figure,
imposing his moral agenda on his
captive.
Similarly,
jigsaws new game draws from another
aspect of early Christianity,
public confession and public pennants
wild today centers can spill their guts
in a low key gossip session with father
superior.
Third Century centers were frequently
required to confess their worst deeds in
front of their entire Church
congregation and act known as Xml,
Jesus,
and also a total bummer according to
early Christian writer Tertullian.
Excellent.
Well,
Jesus was an act meant to humiliate the
center,
essentially rendering them so totally
pathetic.
They would move God to mercy.
Likewise,
Kramer demands the confessions of his
captives in hopes of shaming them.
Once confession was over,
the person moved on to public pennants
where the humiliation only got Richard
Tertullian claims the center would be
instructed by their bishop to do things
like lions,
sackcloth and ashes.
The ashes were a sign of mourning for
your peace,
spiritual condition.
They were forbidden to bape and had to
eat only unseasoned food and drink to
pass.
The time.
Centers would prostrate or lie stretched
out on the ground,
groaning and crying while begging their
church leader and fellow churchgoers to
pray for them.
In Jigsaw,
Anna seems to be taking a similarly
penitent pose as she begs Kramer for
mercy.
So like a third century church leader,
Kramer demands that his captives
publicly confessed their worst deeds and
boy do they clam up the second cigs.
I'll ask them to talk about their past
in previous installments.
The basic human desire to keep both
eyeballs has made for a compelling
reason not to follow jigsaws commands.
This time it's just the characters shame
that makes them reluctant to air their
dirty laundry.
This creates some decidedly baffling
moments.
Best exemplified early on when carly
finds out that Jigsaw has injected her
with a poison that can only be cured by
an antidote found in one of these three
needles.
One is the antidote,
one is harmless and one holds a potent
acid that will melt her face off and not
in the fund.
Electric Daisy carnival way partly
figures out which needle would save her
life because one is numbered.
3.5300000000000002
what does that mean?
Who worse to me,
which is the exact amount of money she
got after robbing and killing someone to
admit that though would serve as a kind
of confession so she doesn't say
anything.
So that happens.
So why wouldn't carly confess?
It seems odd unless you consider the
clue helpfully graffiti tag on the wall.
That sign isn't just there for fire
safety.
It's a reference to John Paul Sartre is
famous play no exit.
First a quick breakdown of the play.
Three dead souls.
Inez is still and Joseph meetup in hell
though this version of hell is less fire
and brimstone and more waiting room.
Wondering how they ended up there.
It's telling Joseph make like the
solving items and lie about their
crimes.
The studio.
Yes.
What have you done?
Where are they send to here?
Well,
that's just it.
I do know.
In fact,
I'm wondering if there hasn't been some
terrible mistake.
Eventually each confesses their worst
deeds.
Both Estelle and Joseph feel the weight
of judgment for their crimes.
So what does this play have to do with
your favorite torture porn series?
Both center around a group of strangers
trapped in a room awaiting an unknown
but presumably horrific punishment.
But perhaps a saw producer was guilty of
wikipedia hang himself because the
eighth film really doubles down on the
no exit shtick in ways,
both big and small.
Notably,
there's an eerie similarity of the
crimes committed by Sartre's character.
Estelle and Jigsaws.
Anna,
uh,
still after becoming pregnant by her
illicit lover,
drowned her newborn baby as he looked on
and he could see what I was up to.
He kept on shouting.
It's style for God's sake,
don't he saw it?
Oh,
he was leaning over the balcony.
He sold the ring spreading on the ward.
The words he killed himself in grief.
That is he wished he made.
He blew his brains out.
Similarly,
Anna suffocated her newborn child,
but convinced her husband it was his
fault forcing him to commit suicide,
but now for the principal's similarity
between jigsaw and no exit,
the emphasis on the painful nature of
confession.
Do you understand why confession is so
hard in both works?
We need to examine sartre idea of the
look which he illustrates through the
following example.
Imagine that you're spying on your
roommates awkward breakup through a
keyhole.
Suddenly you become aware of that your
other cooler roommate is down the
hallway watching you act creepy and
judging you for it.
This state of awareness of being watched
by others is called the look.
When you become aware of the look,
you are forced at least momentarily to
embody the viewpoint of what [inaudible]
calls the other or an outside entity
with its own separate consciousness and
embodying the other's viewpoint.
You feel a major discomfort.
I he shame,
which costs you to pretend that you
weren't spying.
You were just smelling the door knob
extended over a lifetime.
Your awareness of the look causes you to
live in authentically or what Sartre
calls bad faith.
Bad faith is basically a failure to
properly use your freedom or take
responsibility for your actions.
And Kramer's prisoners certainly seem to
be living in the baddest sort of faith.
Take Carly,
despite her clear choice to let a woman
die by not giving her an inhaler,
she sees it as an accident.
However,
searcher would tell carly that even in
choosing not to do anything,
she's still exercised her free will and
made a choice to watch this lady
asphyxiate.
Similarly,
Mitch,
Anna,
and Ryan all lie revising history to
make their crimes seemed like accidents
or honest mistakes.
Kramer essentially accuses his captives
of first being criminals and second of
living in bad faith
in the past who have all put your room
and to see if the world about your
callousness,
your criminality
here.
Notice Kramer's focus not just on each
individual's crimes,
but on their subsequent lies.
Self deception and cover up.
No,
you wouldn't look in the mirror face who
you really are.
The choices you have to feed the hyphen.
You cannot escape the truth.
Sartre,
similarly used the mirror as a metaphor
for the look of the other.
Of course,
Kramer's captives won't look in an
actual mirror.
He means that their crimes will be
reflected back to them by the judgment
of their fellow prisoners.
That judgment can be torture all by
itself,
like a reverse bear trap for your soul
and no exit.
After the characters confess their
crimes,
they suffer anxiety about the judgment
of their peers.
You didn't.
The funeral fret about their reputations
on earth slumped in the chair.
Is that thinking Gaza as a code?
Let's got to think of something that
Jeff Guss on a and beg for reassurance
that they are not bad people.
Just someone just one test would say
positively that I did not run away,
that I'm not the sort of man.
He runs away,
that I'm good and brave and decent and
all the rest of it.
This leads Joseph to utter the famous
line.
How is other people not just because
someone always leave their cell phone on
in the movie theater,
but because the existence of other
people means the existence of their
judgment and the shame that ensues.
That's particularly true.
If like Joseph,
you're hanging out with people who know
your worst secrets.
If Hell is other people knowing your
worst deeds,
it makes sense that confession is
Kramer's new favorite torture device.
He's trying to force his captives who
face Joseph's anguish by making them
publicly take responsibility for their
choices.
For instance,
he makes Ryan relive his own worst deed
as a drunk teenager.
His joy ride inadvertently caused a
deadly car crash.
He escaped responsibility for it and
tell all these years later,
I want to live
now.
Searchers version of hell in no exit is
not the only one that the saw series
references.
John Kramer also must have studied up on
Dante's inferno and it's the 14th
century is how he and poet to picks his
own presumably fictional journey through
the nine concentric circles of health,
each housing eight different brand of
sinners suffering for eternity.
Dante is hell is governed chiefly by a
rule called Contra Paso Latin for to
suffer the opposite.
Under Contra Paso sinners suffer
punishments that are either related to
or the extreme contrast of the crimes
they committed on earth.
For instance,
astrologers and false prophets are
forced to walk forever with their heads
turned backwards.
A punishment for trying to look into the
future or when the powerball chronic
suck ups are buried in excrement
because,
well,
you know,
importantly,
the rule of Contra Pato means that a
person's eternity in hell is predestined
by their own freely chosen sins.
Throughout the saw series,
cramer's show some flair for Contra Paso
punishment.
Think of the time he forced a heroin
junkie to dig through a pit of needles
in search of a key.
Get it like her addiction is the trap or
the cruel money lenders who had to pay
for their lives in pounds of flesh or
the voyeuristic sex offender who had to
gouge his eyes out or lose all his
limbs.
Kramer's traps and Jigsaw also share
some of the same,
uh,
poetry as Dornase and Ferno.
For instance,
we learned that Mitch sold a motorcycle
with a faulty brake to Kramer's nephew
who later died in an accident.
So what was Mitch is trap secure this
brake lever or be sliced up by a
circular metal blade and a jams of the
machine and we think Mitch is saved but
fittingly,
her homemade brake lever is faulty and
Mitch plummets into a death spiral.
Later Kramer presents the last two
survivors,
Anna and Ryan,
what their final game in the form of a
single shotgun and a vague riddle.
If you want to achieve
your freedom,
you have to realize we've been doing it
backwards
and I immediately lunges for the gun.
Assuming that to win the game she has to
shoot Ryan,
but then a broken key falls out.
Cramer had stored the key to their
freedom inside the weapon.
Here,
Anna shows that she hasn't changed.
She remains willing to ruin or take
another life to save her own.
According to Kramer's reasoning,
Anna is ultimately trapped and killed
not by his game,
but by her fundamental moral failings or
jigsaw stops.
Making sense though is when her choice
also Ryan to be trapped in the barn
after he at least somewhat assumes
responsibility for his deadly joy ride.
And from there on Jigsaw seems to
abandon any semblance of a moral lesson
moving from the doomed barn adventures
to the less interesting laser color trap
holding detective Halloran and Logan,
the forensics guy.
They each make their own confessions.
I'm so sorry.
And then logan fakes his death,
comes back to life and reveals that he's
the new jigsaw.
Then he leaves Halloran first debt
savage Logan May be John Kramer's one
man tribute band,
but will he further the moral philosophy
of the series?
Looks like we'll find out soon enough.
There's already talk of a ninth saw
movie with Logan's final declaration I
speak to.
It sounds like we're in for some
forensic pathologists gone wild,
but what do you think was jigsaw and
insightful philosophical inquiry or just
an excuse to watch a guy gets shredded
into confetti and is loken a generic
creep with all the charisma of a latex
glove or the fresh new villain.
The sauce series needed.
Let us know in the comments and as
always,
thanks for watching peace.
If John Kramer's knowledge and skills at
trap building leave you envious.
Head on over to skillshare to pick up
the skills you need to become a
mastermind.
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with more than 18,000
courses and counting.
Skillshare is adding new classes all the
time.
Want to learn how to make films or knit
your own beanie or maybe just take nice
pictures of your friends.
Checkout street shots,
photographing scale,
light and colors taught by none other
then Steve sweatpants.
That's right.
You can learn photography from a guy
named Steve sweatpants or check out the
art of the story,
creating visual narratives taught by
Debbie millman to learn the foundations
of visual storytelling.
There's something here for everyone and
with the class is run by experts in
their fields.
It can't go wrong.
Premium memberships give you unlimited
access to these and thousands of expert
led classes that will teach you to
master and promote your business side
hustle or creative endeavors and with
annual subscriptions starting at less
than $10 a month.
Skillshare is one of the most affordable
learning platforms on the web.
You one of the first thousand people to
sign up at skl dot s h slash wise crack
five or through the link in the
description to get your first two months
of skillshare for just 99 cents.
Follow the link below to get started.
That's all for me.
Thanks for watching y'all peace.
Who would a skill share?
Because that's how I learned here.
Woo.
Excuse,
chair.
Booty says goose get,
we'll share your,
get yourself some skills.